hey everyone what is going on I am so
excited to talk to you guys about the
Batman I can finally talk about it I've
seen it twice I saw it first a few weeks
ago in a private screening room small
screen the second in IMAX and I'm gonna
tell you right now you want to watch
this on the largest screen possible the
visuals the sound I mean it reminds me
of doing it how Dune kind of enveloped
you into the movie you know when we
watched it in IMAX I mean Geneva new
just did a phenomenal job with that Matt
Reeves has done that with the Batman as
soon as you go into the first few scenes
you know you're into a different film it
just kind of transports you into a
completely different world it is
beautiful it is dark it is awesome to
see and speaking of Darkness this is not
a kids Batman movie if you're a parent
and you want to bring your 10 11 12 year
old kid to watch the Batman I would
think twice this is very much in essence
of seven zodiac uh the Joker with
Joaquin Phoenix it is very much in this
era films it is dark it's not as graphic
as some of those films in some scenes
but it edges right there this is a very
adult Batman story and I think for
adults out there and even fans of the
comics who've read some of the graphic
novels who've read some of the uh the
more darker iterations in the comic
series you're going to really appreciate
this but for um people out there that
like someone more of that kind of
comical that fun happy-go-lucky Batman
this is not the character for you it's a
bit scary okay this is a crime story
this is a detective drama and I love
that Matt Reeves has taken all these
elements from various different aspects
of the Batman through his history and
the comics and through different films
and through other films that he's a you
know referenced that he's talked about
like French Connection and Chinatown and
and all these other films and he's
brought it into this world and it makes
it so refreshing because there's a lot
of this film even though we've seen so
many iterations of the Batman right and
we know a lot of his villains already
we've seen some of them on TV and some
of them on film this is a very fresh
film and he's taken some Liberties in
some of the backstories and some other
things he saw it kind of reference some
of the comics and some other films that
we may know of if you watch a lot of
Cinema from years past but he's kind of
made it his own and it's it's just
beautiful to watch honestly I just got
giddy watching this film going yes we
finally get the Detective Comics Batman
that we've been wanting for quite some
time we saw a little you know spurts of
it here and there through various
different films like Nolan's in a little
bit in Burtons but we finally get it in
this one in a way that you are going to
appreciate and if you didn't know that
Batman was quote unquote the world's
greatest detective you're going to find
out very soon he's a pretty badass
detective and he kind of knows his stuff
and it's not just about beating people
down he's actually right up here which
is great to see that
um but this film talking about the film
of the tonality and the visuals in sound
it's awesome you need to see it on the
big screen but this is a long film
coming in around three hours okay uh you
might not want to get up right away at
any point in time because you don't know
what's going to happen next so don't
drink too much before the you watch the
movie or if you you know if you do have
a large bladder okay go for it but if
you don't I would say Sip and enjoy all
right so let's talk about uh some of the
aspects of this film that I really liked
I mentioned I love the crime drama I
love the detective story aspect of it I
love how the Batman and Jim Gordon work
together you see it in the trailers it's
great to see that it really adds another
element to the film we've seen aspects
of it before but you really see it this
time and it just it takes you on this
journey I really really enjoyed it I
loved how the Riddler was implemented
into this film it's a really we have not
seen before do not think Jim Carrey's
Riddler it is very very different uh
this is a psychotic individual who is
willing to go to any lengths to uh
to get his truths this is very scary in
some ways and what's fascinating about
it is what Matt Reeves has done with the
Riddler is and what Paul Dano has done
with this character is that they have
created a character that Izzy almost the
same as Batman
or is he different and that question
comes up time and time again when you
watch this film and it makes you think
Hmm
something to think about this video is
brought to you by secret lab here at
geek culture we love our secret lab
chairs especially the all-new 2022 Titan
Evo with its revamped four-way lumbar
system for enhanced back support EP
leather 2.0 isn't your cup of tea then
consider the all-new softweave even more
soft and breathable than before the
chair comes in more colors including
this lovely Frost Bloom the Titan Evo is
even magnetized allowing the head pillow
to stick on the headrest without straps
of course there are even more new
features so do check them out at
seekerlab.co
fascinating how they did a deep dive
into the psyche of the Riddler which is
I I like that because you know we always
see these characters in the comics in an
animated series or even in the movies
and sometimes we don't think what makes
them tick I think Nolan try to get into
that a bit more but I think Matt Reeves
is digging into it deeper and it really
makes it fascinating to watch speaking
of that we have to talk about the Batman
and Robert Pattinson
guys
he is phenomenal as Batman and he's
fantastic as Bruce Wayne it's a very
different Bruce Wayne that we've seen
before and a very different Batman Okay
in terms of Batman let me take that back
there are some times you're watching it
it feels very much bail-esque not the
voice but in terms of his mannerisms but
he has a very different Outlook and this
Batman at times as you saw in the
trailer is uncontrollable uh or at least
we feel that he is I mean and what
Robert Pattinson and Matt Ruiz has done
with this character is Batman is not
quite all there
um
I don't want to say that
I want to say something I don't want to
be insensitive but I feel like you could
almost say this Bruce Wayne is on the
Spectrum in some ways I mean obviously
he's been heavily affected by the death
of his parents and by things that have
happened but how he deals with this and
how he deals with the world and people
around him and just Society
and his his Focus it's it does remind
you of somebody who could be on the
Spectrum and there's nothing wrong with
that it's just that's part and parcel
everybody has a uniqueness to them and
this Bruce Wayne has something than him
that has just it just drives him to a
point and it's that you kind of go
you get a little uncomfortable at times
with this Batman you kind of go is he
going too far this I'm not used to
seeing this on the Silver Screen
but it works beautifully and Robert
Pattinson is just he's the he's the
perfect actor for this honestly
the this is fantastic I mean I could see
him being nominated for best actor I
could and I can say the Batman Robert
Pattinson yes I could see him being
nominated for best actor for this
performance it is that good speaking of
Batman we're going to talk about Jim
Gordon Jeffrey Wright I love the
chemistry between these two these are
the two detectives on the prowl on to
find what the Riddler is about who's his
next victim is what's going on what's
his motivation I love the pairing with
these two we get this in the comics
quite a bit we never really saw it well
we did see a little bit of it in the
Nolan trilogy but you see it a bit more
here and Jeffrey Wright does a
tremendous job with Jim Gordon I mean it
very much is in the essence of Gary
Oldman but he has his own take on it and
I just love what he did with it he
really did he's right there with the
Batman in a lot of ways obviously they
have a different Outlook and what things
they can do based on the law one's a
vigilante one is a captain but
it's interesting how they interact with
each other and how they look after each
other and
you could see I I cannot wait to see
where Matt Reeves takes these two into
the next film or to the next film I'm
excited to see this journey it really
made it fun to watch now let's talk
about Catwoman or Zoe Kravitz becoming
the Catwoman because she's not quite
Catwoman yet but very much in essence
but this is kind of a different Catwoman
that we've seen before I prefer this
much more than the Anne Hathaway version
I like Hannah Hathaway but I feel Zoe
Kravitz really encapsulates this
character she just knocked out of the
park she's sensual she's sexy she's
driven she's a badass uh this is going
to make her a huge star I mean she's
already up and coming and she's been
doing some great work this is going to
make her a huge star I mean what
Catwoman did for Michelle Pfeiffer I
think Zoe Kravitz is the new era that
this is really going to be an awesome
character for her and I can't wait to
see what she does with it going into the
future with it
um her backstory is very different than
what we've seen in other film iterations
out there if you're into the comics you
might I see some things I'm not going to
give anything away because these are
some of the more surprising elements of
the movie because there's a lot of
different characters they all sort of
interact with each other but I think
there's a fresh take for some of you who
may not be into the comic verse as much
as others you're going to like what
they've done with her character and how
they've brought her into the world of
Gotham let's just put it that way so
let's talk about the penguin I'm gonna
say this Colin Farrell I said Robert
Pattinson should be nominated for best
actor and Academy Awards Colin Farrell
should be nominated for best supporting
actor honestly you don't know it's him
if you didn't see him in interviews and
you did not uh see the credits or looked
on the uh the web
you would have no idea it's him there's
not one ounce of the Penguin's
mannerisms that even resembles Colin
Farrell they've done such a tremendous
job with the makeup the Prosthetics but
it's not even just that it's his acting
I mean he you know what reminds me of
I'm gonna go back a few years in films
The Untouchables when Robert De Niro
played Al Capone he reminds me of the
character Al Capone there's a lot of his
uh character nuances in the way that he
speaks and his mannerisms that reminded
me of that I'm like wow and sometimes at
one moment I'm thinking why did Matt
Reeves just ask Robert De Niro to do
this part because honestly speaking I
mean you could have put De Niro in there
and it had been like okay there it is
because
Colin Farrell is it's awesome what he
did with this as an actor myself who's
acted in TV series here and in some
films I'm Blown Away by his performance
I am just awestruck by it he's got to be
nominated he's not then I don't know
what the academy is thinking because
this guy is awesome let's talk about the
Riddler a little bit more Paul Dano as I
mentioned earlier on to it psychotic a
little bit crazy uh very much in essence
of is he very similar to Bruce Wayne or
not but Paul Dano has really taken this
uh character into a different realm
there are aspects of the Heath Ledger's
Joker that you're going to see in some
parts of the Riddler here and there's
other aspects that he really makes it
his own and and really kind of crafting
this sort of the
the The psychosis of this character in a
way that really makes you
if it's very fascinating to watch and I
think what I like what Matt Reeves has
done with the Riddler with the Batman is
he really delves into the mental aspect
of these characters and I mentioned that
before but still you really it's part
and parcel with what how these actors
are portraying it and as such I mean
having said that I don't know where Matt
Reeves is going to go for let's say a
villain in the next Batman movie because
I'm sure there's gonna be a second one
after this there's gonna be for sure
because this Riddler is kind of all the
things that we've seen in the past from
The Joker and other characters now not
in essence of the strength of Bane
but in the mental aspect he's got it all
covered so it's going to be
procrastinating to see where Matt Reeves
takes this story and takes these
characters and takes the to find the
next villain who will it be because I
mean Paul Daniels just put them all into
under one umbrella and then called him
the Riddler and it's just man he's
effing crazy man he is crazy
fun to watch you're gonna enjoy it and
he's creepy as hell uh let's talk about
John Turturro for a moment um Carmine
Falcone now in the trailers we see him a
little bit but I will say that he is a
bigger presence in this film than the
movies that made him out to be I'm not
going to spoil anything for you guys but
he is an integral part to this story to
this film and he plays it brilliantly he
doesn't go over the top as this sort of
kind of crime kind of you know mafioso
kind of guy he bring he plays a close of
the heart but it is a beautiful
performance by John Turturro he's scary
as hell man he's he's one of these guys
you could watch uh you know watch The
Sopranos or watch Goodfellas you're
going
yes he could be right into those films
and he'd be scary and he'd be fit right
in and it is it's awesome to see him so
let's talk about Andy Circus as Alfred
and I like where they're taking Alfred
because we've seen Alfred portrayed in
many different ways Michael Kane did it
and we had other actors who did in the
past this Alfred you could see he was
the one to sort of train Bruce Wayne he
was the kind of one that kind of helped
create this Persona of the Batman
um because Andy Circus is a very
physical actor and you see a little bit
of that in his in his characterization
of Alfred I don't want to spoil too much
I mean there are some integral moments
with Alfred but I would have liked to
see more I'll just put it out I would
have liked to see more of Alfred in this
film hopefully Matt Reeves does uh dig
deeper into the relationship going into
the you know the next movies because
there's a lot to uncover and because
these are different actors portraying
each of the characters there's a
different chemistry there's a different
backstory it would be it would be great
to see how they interact in a much more
uh deeper Essence but now let's talk
about the length of this film in my my
final thoughts on it um there's a
there's a part of the story where you
think it's going to end
um because it kind of wraps up you know
the main storyline for that for the most
part right I mean they leave some things
unturned but every movie is going to do
that however it's almost like Warner
Brothers said you know Matt we love this
script we love what you're doing with
the Batman but we need a climactic
ending we need something bigger we need
something that's going to be the Batman
people know and we want that kind of
oomph that larger Grand scale you know
climactic ending
and so the film takes a different turn
and it almost feels like an afterthought
in some ways like it didn't need to end
there you could have ended it right at
this point it would have been fine and
yes it's not a CL you know a climactic
ending in a way where it's like you know
Wing bang bang explosions and all that
kind of stuff but that's fine because
the movie is not like that but it's very
Compact and it's very small in regard it
kind of reminds me of Daredevil in the
Netflix series it kind of keeps it like
that right it does I mean at the end of
it it does sort of um kind of help
complete Batman's journey in some ways
but you could have already added that
into one portion of the film there's one
other aspect of the film I felt was a
little bit it kind of threw you out of
it it was a small scene you see a little
bit in the trailer when uh the Batman
jumps from a tall building in his wing
suit which is kind of like a parachute
suit but when you see him flying you
know flying through Gotham or gliding
through it because it is a real suit and
you do glide with these things there's a
part of that scene where you just feel
it's just so unrealistic and I kind of
felt like they were trying to figure out
an interesting way to get out of it but
as a result they kind of pull you out of
the movie for a moment of that realism
that groundedness of the Batman you're
kind of like
yeah that's a little bit of a a cheap
way to get out of it you know come on
Matt you've been doing such a great job
why'd you do that but they get out of it
really quick and they never reference it
again my final thoughts on the Batman
this is a very violent Batman the
fighting is awesome it's very visceral
it's very violent uh this is a Batman
that does not hold a punch in any way
shape or form unless he wants to
um I love the detective aspect to it it
is very dark it is very cerebral it is a
very this is a movie that will challenge
the mentality of even your hero in a lot
of ways that's going to kind of put
things in perspective in a unique way
that I think is fascinating and
refreshing there's a lot of interesting
takes to the backstories of some of the
characters that I don't want to give
away because that's spoiler territory
but it is refreshing as well but I just
absolutely loved this film it is the
Batman film I've been wanting to see on
the Silver Screen for quite some time
The Dark Knight was my favorite Batman
movie thus far one of my favorite films
of all time and this is right up there
with it it is really that good I don't
know where Matt Reeves is going to go
with another film but
we'll find out
he's put basically two films into one
with this one so anyway those are my
thoughts on the Batman let me know your
thoughts in the comment section below do
you agree with me do you disagree with
me any thoughts you have I'd love to
hear from you guys subscribe to the
channel if you can like this video take
care stay safe and I'll chat to you soon